salty sweet chewy crunchy it's a
delicious combination born from one of
black America's most consequential
cultural movements it was the 1930s the
place was New York City
it was the epicenter of black Americans
movement into mainstream culture the
Harlem Renaissance artists writers and
thinkers we gather at venues and Harlem
into the wee hours of the morning
listening to touring big bands and jazz
artists as the club stayed open later
and later
so did local restaurants to take in the
hungry concert goers one such restaurant
owner was Joseph T Wells founder of
Wells supper club Wells became known for
its southern inspired menu but Wells
needed a hit to stay on top of the 2
a.m. restaurant business what could he
do
seeing an opportunity Wells realized
that the fried chicken leftovers from
dinner could be served with the freshly
prepared waffles for breakfast creating
a sweet and savory concoction unlike
anything else the dish was a hit
eventually word got out and chicken and
waffles became a soul food staple from
Atlanta to Los Angeles and though Wells
closed in 1982 the dish lives on so when
you think of the Harlem Renaissance take
Duke Ellington jazz Plains and Hughes
poetry and Joseph T Wells chicken and
waffles this is a California roll and it
was probably invented in Japan Oh
California nope it was invented in
Canada this is chef Tojo right
hi mrs. Schaeffer Joe he holds make
sushi one of the most popular foods in
the US and Canada but to understand this
we have to take a look back it was 1971
and sushi wasn't popular when it came to
Japanese food people only liked a couple
things just people eat eat tempura and
also teriyaki
turns out North Americans they did not
like see me no no no way look terrible
they said some people yeah do you know
so Tojo did something crazy he wrapped
the rice on the outside of the CV to
hide it in Japan people they passing me
well this is a wrong idea wrong idea but
people like it and chef Tojo he did not
stop there okay everybody eat cucumber
avocado and cooked crab just I change
this preparation just low so he rolled
these preferred ingredients into one
beautiful amazing cuisine changing roll
I didn't quote Zhu California Lord we
called inside uncle where it is it got
the name California roll because it was
so popular with people who came to his
restaurant from a life and the roll made
people think differently about sushi it
was some sort of gateway roll people
starting with California law oh this is
very good then smoked salmon and tuna
step by step they loved it
chef Tojo's beginner roll was such a
success Japan's Ministry of Agriculture
Forestry and Fisheries appointed him as
the nation's goodwill ambassador for
Japanese cuisine and now sushi is
everywhere stickers on your notebook USB
drives play-doh molds wooden toys sets
everywhere maybe not all thanks to chef
Tojo but definitely partly whether
you're in it for the bottomless mimosas
the decadent pancakes or the avocado
toast brunch is hands down and the best
part of the weekend
while enjoying the finer things in life
did you ever stop to think about how
this glorious eating tradition began
well it all started with a man a man
with a hangover back in 1895 there was
this guy named well guy and he was a
writer living in England at that time
sundays were a big deal an early post
church meat heavy meals were all the
rage but for those nursing a hangover
and recovering from the previous night's
debauchery those meals weren't always
appetizing so guy proposed a compromise
and penned a prolific essay
appropriately named brunch a plea he
envisioned a hybrid meal of sorts that
was lighter than the typical meat spread
and included a variety of pastries
friends could gossip about the previous
night's indiscretions while chasing
their hangovers with some hair of the
dog but the delicious British invention
took what seems like forever 30 years to
catch on in the States when it did
Sunday morning never looked the same
again so the next time you're enjoying a
french toast chased by a Bloody Mary
take a second to thank the hard drinking
Englishmen by the name of God is this a
sandwich how about this or this the
answer is well it depends
[Music]
it's actually surprisingly complicated
jurisdiction scheme that's Neil Fortin
he's a professor of food law he wrote
the book on it literally just what a
sandwich is is actually defined by the
government
federally it's the USDA and the FDA
defining something matters because it
changes how it's inspected and regulated
the hotdog is regulated by USDA but a
hotdog on a bun is regulated by FDA a
sandwich doesn't have actually a strict
legal definition it's more of the common
term that can lead to some heated
arguments by sandwich purists according
to the USDA the hotdog is not a sandwich
but the dictionary says it is and so
does the state of New York
Mirek is pretty inclusive on the
sandwich question hi I'm David Greco
this is Mike's deli in the real Little
Italy of the Bronx our list of
sandwiches is at least fifty sandwiches
we have the Bronx Tale the Michelangelo
Sophie Lorraine the Raging Bull the
Yankee big boy come on I'll make you one
special that's a New York sandwich
according to the state's Department of
Taxation and Finance not only is a
hotdog a sandwich but so is a burrito
that's because a burrito counts as a rap
which in New York is a sandwich okay so
what about this it looks and acts like a
sandwich it's an ice-cream sandwiches
sandwiches I would say that ice cream
sandwiches is a fanciful name rather
than an actual use of the word sandwich
in the traditional sense fanciful named
delicious sandwich the USDA
but what do they know however sandwiches
define we know that there are all kinds
of delicious food law is it's well
simpler and much more complicated than
it looks on the surface thanks Neil it's
red and pricey it's a critter and a
delicacy it's the creme de la creme of
seafood but this beloved summertime
favorite was once thought of as the poor
man's food say what it is said that in
the early 16th century as the first
pilgrims began to settle in Bay Area's
of America that the oceans overfloweth
with lobster no literally they
overfloweth imagine a shore with a
lobster wall 2 feet tall as one would
expect the settlers ate them up until
like anything eaten 3 times a day they
got sick of them eventually deeming them
the cockroaches of the sea after that
lobsters were used as fertilizer fish
bait and ultimately prison food they
were fed so often to inmates that there
was even a law enacted to protect said
inmates from cruel and unusual lobster
punishment so then how did lobster
become the succulent delicacy we all
know and love fast forward to the mid
1800s canned food became a thing as did
the railroad lobsters were canned and
shipped to middle America at the same
time middle Americans started travelling
to New England for fresh lobster by the
late 1880s prices began to surge and by
World War two lobsters became the pricey
specialty we've all grown to enjoy
you